DONALD TRUMP LAWYERS HAVE NEVER
ARGUED IN COURT THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED THESE DOUMGTS.
T
DOCUMENTER.
THE FORMER SAID SAID THAT
HIMSELF.
THEY HAVE NOT ARGUED HATHAT IN
COURT AND WE'D THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE A PRETTY POWERFUL
ARGUMENT TO MAKE TO THE JUDGE.
SOMEONE ELSE THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAID IN THAT INTERVIEW
GIVES UNEASE.
LISTEN.
>> IF IT HAPPENED, I THINK THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY THE LIKES OF WHICH
PERHAPS WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES WOULD STAND FOR
IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS, MR.
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK YOU'D HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS.
BIG PROBLEMS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY WOULD
STAND FOR IT.
THEY WILL NOT SIT STILL AND
STAND FOR THIS ULTIMATE OF
HOAXES.
>> THE CORRECT ANSWER IS ME AND
MY LEGAL TIME WOULD FIGHT IT IN
COURT AND PROVE MY INNOCENCE.
AS OPPOSED HE SAYS THAT HE IS
NOT SAYING ANY SUCH THING, BUT
WE LIVED THROUGH JANUARY 6 AND
WE UNDERSTAND HOW TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TAKE CUES FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
HOW DOES THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DEAL WITH THAT KNOWING THAT HE
WILL STIR THIS UP?
>> YOU CANNOT IGNORE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT IS A
THREAT.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THAT IS A
AND YOU ALREADY SEE THAT IN
THESE DOCUMENTS THEY ARE HIDING
THE KNEENAMES OF THE LAWYERS AN
AGENTS WORKING ON THIS CASE
BECAUSE OF THE THREATS THAT THEY
ARE RECEIVING FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS.
THAT IS NOT NORMAL.
>> NOT NORMAL.
TRUMP YESTERDAY WHEN HE WAS ON
HUGH HEWITT'S SHOW AND HE WAS
ASKED WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU WERE
INDICTED.
>> IF IT HAPPENED, I THINK THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY THE LIKES OF WHICH
PERHAPS WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE PEOPLE OF
UNITED STATES WOULD STAND FOR
IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS?
>> I THINK YOU'D HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS.
BIG PROBLEMS.
>> SOUNDS LIKE ABOUT WHAT WE
WERE HERR IHEARING FROM HIM BEF
JANUARY 6.
>> WHAT SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAID WAS EVEN WORSE WHEN HE
TALKED ABOUT POSSIBLE RIOTS IN
THE STREETS.
THIS INDEPENDENT REVIEW BY THE
JUDICIARY HOPEFULLY WILL BRING
AROUND PUBLIC OPINION.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED.
BUT ULTIMATELY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILL NOT BE INFLUENCED
BY THOSE TYPES OF THREATS AND WE
SHOULD ALL DISTANCE OURSELVES
FROM THREATS.
>> SO YOU SEE THOSE AS THREATS?
>> WELL, LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID YOU
WILL SEE RIOTING IN THE STREETS
IF THERE IS A CHARGE BROUGHT.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THE FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> WORDS WHICH PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCLINED TO BE DANGEROUS WILL
INTERPRET AS THREATS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S MIND.
>> AND THE SAME ISSUE WE HAD ON
JANUARY 6.
HE WAS INCITING THOSE PEOPLE AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HE IS DOING
NOW.
HE IS PREPARING HIS BASE TO
FORMEN A ATTACK IF HE WERE TO BE
ARRESTED.
SO HERE WE GO AGAIN.